I'm sure he'll be I'm an hour I'm mamrie
Hart no relation or is there when we are
in the upcoming film very very exciting
things to tell you about the release of
dirty 30 which is coming out September
23rd however you have the opportunity to
see it in an actual movie theater before
it actually comes out so cold in 30 30
movie calm and you're gonna find a list
of cities in which you can reserve
tickets to watch the movie ahead of time
however if you don't go an RSVP for the
movie they might not show up to your
city so be sure to check out with the
city closest to you is and let us know
that you're going to go because the more
people that reserve in a singular city
the more chance that the movie will be
at a theater in that city we need to get
a certain number of people RSVP to those
events and we get to show you our film
in an actual movie theater here with
other people you need to do it because
if you thought my face looks good this
big imagine seeing it on the big screen
the biggest of all Wow I mean finally
our faces will match the size of our
egos yes and it's going to be available
in 3d though not that's why it's not
sure that's a lot but what is true is
that if you find there are no major
cities near you you can also request a
special event in your town so you don't
have to feel left out if you're not
close to any of the cities that are
already pre listed on dirty 30 calm
there's going to be special
behind-the-scenes footage shown at these
screenings and possibly a little
exclusive gift one of the best parts
about going to these screenings is you
can see who else in a town nearby loves
what we do this doesn't forgive it you
from also pre-ordering the film and
unloading it so you can watch it again
and again
the comfort of your own home afterwards
do it all have it all hey